[Music]
how long is it been I don't know two
years maybe you're getting something
this weekend straight up you're gonna
get at least two dicks this weekend for
crying out loud Dina we only gonna be
there for three days
well three dicks then you know what I
need you to use your lady mouse I need
you to use your lady mouth we haven't
hung in five years
this creature is about us we are here
together today is the last day that we
will ever be this young I'll also get
pregnant almost ready
this is hand-stitched embroidery from a
tribe in Guatemala so they're not
[ __ ] in Guatemala bin bumpkins we got
[ __ ] to do so buckle up [ __ ] who come
to stand up late creep in making
memories that we can laugh about for the
rest of our lives
because that's what a girls trip is for
girls I have to pee look the line is
short over there there's a long line in
the bathroom here just go for it
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
move you are it's not my arm oh that's
that Shaka Zulu right there you know I
got some bomb-ass push if you want to
take the hit
we need you huh way to stand out shine
you know what that can cause a lot of
infection heard you can y'know infection
in your booty ho
if the booty up hi hello my god
I am Renzo I've achieved puberty and I'm
in a rock band I will syrup and level
cervix puberty
I'm Francie Miller's first nanny I can
smell